-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with Dave
Chappelle, ladies and gentleman.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Hey.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Caught me smoking.
-That's right.
We caught you smoking.
But, Dave, I remember
when I used to -- I used to --
I got on the same bill as you
back in '97, something like that
at The Improv,
and you used to smoke --
-I remember that night
very well.
And you killed.
-Yeah, you remember that?
I was like --
-Yeah, you used to
have the guitar.
I remember the whole thing.
-Yeah, exactly.
I was like, "Man."
But I remember just watching,
and, you know, all the comics
would sit around the side
and just watch each other.
We watched all the comics.
And smoking was a big part
of your kind of timing.
-It very much is.
I'll show you how it's done.
[ Laughter ]
Nailed it.
-[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
But then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
But then I read somewhere
that you started stand-up
when you were 14.
Is that possible?
-It was.
My mother -- My mother used to
have to bring me to the clubs,
which was kind of a nightmare,
'cause I was filthy.
'Cause, you know,
when I was young, I just --
I just thought being dirty
was the way to go.
-Yeah.
-But it was a weird
and wonderful experience.
I wouldn't trade it
for anything.
It didn't seem crazy to me
at the time, but when I look
at my kids, I say,
"That was crazy."
-Yeah.
But, the one thing
I do love about you, too,
is you never forget D.C.
You never forget
actually where you came from,
where you started, and when
you won that Mark Twain Prize,
you actually went back
and you did a master class
for your high school,
with a local high school.
-Oh, my God, yes.
That was the best part of it.
[ Clears throat ] Excuse me.
And by the way, Jimmy,
I got to tell you
before I tell the story,
I love you to death.
Um, I went to Duke Ellington
School of the Arts
in Washington, D.C.
And that place changed my life.
It's partially privately funded.
It's a public school,
but the arts program
is why they always try
to get donations.
And it is one of the best
incubators to hone your talent
that I've ever witnessed.
And Bradley Cooper
and Chris Tucker and Common
and Erykah Badu and all my
friends who were at the awards,
the Mark Twain Awards.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, they all went to
the school with me the next day
and taught master classes
for the kids.
It was the most beautiful day,
I think, I've ever lived
in my life.
It meant so much to me.
-That was so cool
for those kids.
-Yeah, those kids are the best.
Matter of fact, there's a bunch
of my buddies from high school
with me right now.
I got a whole crowd
right in here.
-Let me see.
-[ Laughter ]
-Wait. What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, come on. That's a first.
I think you're the first guest
to bring their own crowd.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Always doing everything first!
Always doing everything first!
I want to talk to you about your
podcast, "Midnight Miracle."
-Ooh, yes. Yes, indeed.
-It's available now.
It's on Luminary.
Talib Kweli and Yasiin Bey
are your co-hosts on this.
-The greatest partners ever.
-Yeah. They are unbelievable.
Yeah. How did this come about?
-We all -- We were all in Ohio,
and there was a tornado,
so we all --
There was like 20 of us --
We had to hide in my basement.
It was hilarious.
-[ Laughter ]
-Gosh.
And, you know -- you know,
a tornado sounds like
a freight train's coming, but
there's no train tracks here.
We're talking.
It's a little stressful.
And in the middle
of all this stress,
Mos goes,
"We should do a podcast."
[ Laughter ]
And we did it. And we did it.
-You just did it. Yeah.
-And doing this podcast
is one of the most favorite
I've ever done in my career.
Just being able to spend time
with my friends
and laugh about stuff
and reminisce about stuff
and figure stuff out.
It's been wonderful.
-How do you describe the show?
-Well, you know, it's funny.
You keep holding the thing up --
All these episodes will exist
on vinyl, ultimately.
-What?!
-So it's like --
Yeah, they're gonna be on vinyl.
-Wait. This is a brilliant idea.
-I'm going the other direction.
It's beautiful, man.
And we do --
So, they're all like 25 minutes,
but they're great.
I can't even -- I don't even
know how to describe it.
It's like a variety show on wax.
-Yeah.
But it's --
'Cause it's music, as well.
I mean, Black Star
on the second episode,
they debuted a new song, the
first time you've heard from --
-In over two decades,
the first time they recorded
as Black Star.
-Wow.
-The song is produced by Madlib,
who is an amazing
hip-hop producer.
And you're gonna hear it
on the "Midnight Miracle" first.
It's beautiful.
-I love that you're always
doing it, you're always
pushing the boundaries
and just trying something.
Even though it's vinyl,
it's new, in a weird way.
No one's doing this.
I think it's so fun.
You're involved with the
musical performance tonight,
which is our first live
performance since we shut down,
for a crowd, for an audience.
-Oh, man, this is exciting.
Shout-out to J.Period, too.
-J.Period.
And Tiffany Gouché
and Black Thought, obviously.
-You know my guy.
Yeah, what up, Black Thought?
-What up, what up,
what up, what up?
-They said that you're --
-"I'm cooler than a cooler
inside of a cooler."
He knows what that means.
-[ Laughs ]
-You're providing
narration for this,
so tell me
about this collaboration.
-J.Period is, like, the homey.
If you're into mixtapes,
he got some of the fieriest
mixtapes that come out.
You know what I mean?
There was a Tribe Called Quest
mixtape that I was crazy about.
His Lauryn Hill mixtapes.
There's probably a few volumes
of that -- those are crazy.
So, whenever someone wants
to get a dope mixtape done,
that's the guy to go to.
So me and J.Period met.
He's going to be rocking
with us on some things
on "Midnight Miracle."
And I'm happy
he's on the show tonight.
And I'm happy Nikki's on
the show. Shout-out to Nikki.
I don't know where she's at,
but give her my love.
-Yeah. Nikki Glaser.
Yeah, yeah, she's on the show.
Exactly. We'll talk more
about the performance.
But, also, we have
another fun bit. Just --
Everyone just stay tuned.
More with Dave Chappelle
when we come back.